listen how can you not be a Rodney fan
hey you know you only had great Rodney
story oh 100 I do so maybe Rodney
Dangerfield I'm like 16 17 years old and
he um I suppose I'm getting ready to go
up on stage and Rodney comes and he
bumps me and he gets hey you can't go up
Rodney's going on so Rodney goes on and
he kills and I'm like I'm gonna go up
after Rodney and so no one's going to go
up so I went up after him and I do my
stuff uh and afterward Rodney is like
Hey kid what are you going to go with
all that stuff well that's cursing you
know and using it the language he like
gave me basically told me I wasn't [ __ ]
so I was like oh I was Crest falling
down when mine was blown and I was like
Rodney didn't like me he thought I was
too dirty and long story short maybe two
three years later I blew up and I'd
become you know Eddie hot shot and I was
at the uh uh in the bathroom in Caesar's
Palace gone at the urinal and
Dangerfield comes and stands right next
to me I got go over and he looks and
says hey who knew
[Laughter]
but oh yeah now we can do the interview
what were you saying oh you're gonna say
first of all that's that's awesome but
the thing I love about me is he said the
same jokes again and again over the
course of 10 years I ate up every single
one of them could say the same thing
it's the character it's the character
and the delivery you'll laugh every time
you see it like if you watch archibanka
if you watch the Sanford and Son and
they made you laugh every time you
watched that episode it'll make you
laugh it's the character